- [Interviewer] All right, Queen.
- Yes.
- Queen, where'd you grow
up, where're you from?
- I'm born and raised
from Brooklyn, New York.
I'm from the Bronx.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood,
you grew up with both of your parents?
- I started off, yeah
with both of my parents
and then my father left when
I was at least 10 years old,
and then I end up losing
my mother when I was 14.
- [Interviewer] How did you lose your mom?
- She had a seizure at work and collapsed
and never woke back up.
- [Interviewer] So she died or?
- She yeah, she died when I was 14.
- [Interviewer] Oh my God, sorry.
- So since then I was
getting passed around
from family to family,
and it just wasn't working out.
- [Interviewer] That's
a rough childhood then.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And, where'd
your life go from there,
did you...
- I end up having to
come out to California
when I was around 15,
out there I was getting
in a lot of trouble,
so after my mom died like
I end up going to juvenile.
Just, you know it just
start getting crazy,
so my family out there
made me come down here
to my father's side of the family.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- And I stayed in Oakland, California for,
at least most of my life, from there on
and then I just recently
moved out here to LA.
So, I've been out here for like
a year and a half right now.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
And how was your childhood
rather than losing your parents?
- It's been...
It's been hard I'll just say that.
I was going through a lot,
basically my whole life
since my mom passed away,
like I wasn't listening
to none of my family.
My father was barely in my life like,
he was in and out.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I'm not really having contact
with him at this moment,
like we talk but it doesn't
go good with our conversation.
- [Interviewer] Right.
Also, I end up getting pregnant as well,
so I have a one year old, named Ezekiel.
And now my father's trying
come back in my life
but it's like,
and tell me how to raise my
son but I'm just like it's not.
Yeah, I have like no respect
for him at this moment.
- [Interviewer] So you're working
a Street down on Figueroa?
- Yes, I am.
I started there when I was
18 years old, so I'm 22 now.
I played the Fig, west end so.
- [Interviewer] Do you work
for a pimp or you on your own?
- No, I'm on my own.
- You're on your own?
- Yeah.
- So tell me about that,
is that difficult at times?
- It can be but it's,
when you know you get approached
by another you know guy,
but you know it's a lesson learned
it's like the only way at this moment
to you know take care of
me and my son, so yeah.
- [Interviewer] There's a lot of girls
that are doing this now right?
- Yeah, I'm not the only one,
there's over probably a thousand
girls out there right now
there's a really lot.
You know some, it's just
been crazy out there lately,
you know it's been girls getting chased.
I've got chased multiple
times out there by like
another pimp or like
yeah, just weird people.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
and everything's illegal
so it's like both sides.
- It is, but with that is the
cops just don't wanna see you
in the middle of the street.
Like if you're on the
side walk that's fine,
but they just don't wanna see you
in the middle of the street
or walking up to a car.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So the cops tend to leave
you alone a little bit?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how many
customers would you pick up
in a day, in a night?
- It depends on if it's slow or like busy,
but when it's slow it
would like at least one,
two or three a day, sometimes four.
But if it's really, really
busy it's up to like,
I'd say the highest I had
was like eight to nine dates
and yeah it's crazy.
I'll just say it's crazy.
(laughs) It's really crazy.
- [Interviewer] I bet.
And what do you charge for your services?
- The lowest I do is 60, but
the highest is like 80 to a 100
you know, 150, 250 yeah so.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And you're having sex,
you're doing everything?
- Sometimes yeah,
sometimes I do with them,
sometimes they just
wanna sit down and talk,
or like I had a lot of them
who just ran out their whole
life story to me about their wives--
- [Interviewer] They just
want to talk to a woman?
- Yeah, I get picked out
of a whole lot of girls
in the street it be so funny,
but yeah most of them
I mostly talk to them,
I don't really just do anything with them
so that's like easy money,
- [Interviewer] That is interesting.
It's really easy money right there.
- [Interviewer] It's really
easy, I should charge for that.
- Oh. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] That's what I'm doing.
So your child, who takes care of your son?
- My auntie right now, it's
between my sister and my auntie
they kinda switch off.
- [Interviewer] But he lives with you?
- Yeah, he stays with--
- [Interviewer] But when
you're working they help out?
- Yeah, he's like in a day
care and then like from there
they pick him up, they choose
who's gonna pick him up.
- [Interviewer] And
have you been arrested?
- I have, actually a couple weeks ago
I got setup by a girl down there,
I guess she was like undercover,
but she was also like
on the blade as well so,
it's kinda you know, upsetting
but I had to go through it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
When you were a young girl
did you have dreams of a
different life of yourself?
- [Interviewer] I did I had a dream,
like I really had a dream
of like getting married
and like moving out of state.
Like I had like this big
whole you know dream of like
moving to Hawaii and doing all this,
but it didn't go as planned growing up.
My whole life was just a
living hell I'll just say that.
- [Interviewer] Do you
depressed sometimes?
- I do a lot, and like I
break down most of the time.
I'm not gonna lie, I'm a cry baby.
I'm a cry baby, but I'm
actually like mean as well,
I get a lot people telling me I'm mean,
but I'm a really big cry
baby I'm not gonna lie like
I've been crying for like
the past couple of days
'cause like I've been so stressed out.
I'm just like, I don't know
like I've been not wanting to do this,
I've been wanting to stop doing this
but I end up, no just
like no I'm just gonna
go along with it and look
at me now I'm still here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah
where else can you make
that kinda money that quickly
- Getting a job you know.
- [Interviewer] But you won't
be able to make you know
$500, $600 in a night.
- The lotto, just playing
the lotto. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] I mean
eventually perhaps you would,
but not right away.
- Right away no, I'm
just like right now I'm--
- [Interviewer] You need
to pay bills right now?
- Yeah, there's no time
to wait for the big lotto
to come so no it's working on the streets.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- I did, I graduated
2016, that's what I did do
I finished high school it
was that or do four years
and I was just like no, so
I went through high school
without getting in trouble,
my whole senior year
and I graduated, so I end up
getting taken off probation.
- [Interviewer] I'm gonna
ask a stupid question,
but how do your dad not in the
picture and losing your mom
at such an early age, almost
made this inevitable for you?
- Yeah, cause I'm just--
- [Interviewer] 'Cause like if
you had both of your parents
in your lives you probably would've lived
a very different life.
- Yeah, I think I would
or if my mother was here,
'cause me and my mother
were like best friends
like that was my best friend my ride--
I could go to her for anything.
So when I lost her at that moment
I just like forget everyone you know.
I gave up on everything,
and then I end up going down a wrong path
and this is what it led me to,
working on the street.
- [Interviewer] All right Queen,
well thank you so much for talking to me.
- Thank you too.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with your future,
and your son, and everything else.
- Thank you.